bring you a bit of breaking news that's
just come into us here at Sky News and
it concerns Harry Kane the England and
Tottenham Striker who has just become
England's all-time leading goal scorer
with a penalty against Italy in Naples
it's England a win winning the game by
two gold still and Harry Kane has
overtaken a white overtaken Wayne Rooney
to become the leading goal scorer for
England with a penalty in the uh Opening
match of the qualification group for the
Euro championships in a 2024 Harry
Kane's penalty has put him top of the
charts ahead of Rooney so celebrations
for Harry tonight and also England
winning 2-0 against Italy of course the
team that beat England in the last Euros
finals on penalty so looking good for
the three lines tonight